[Musique]
c'était le 8 décembre
1867 il vient maintenant 150 ans
l'arrivée à versailles de la première
course cycliste des grosses roues en
bois des costumes d'époque d'une
reconstitution de ce paris versailles
avec deux véritables vélocipède
l'ancêtre de la petite reine développé
par la famille olivier
et roues sont pas exactement dans laxe
donc il faut faire extrêmement attention
les pédales sont complètement fixé à la
roue avant c'est pas évident pour
freiner il faut pas se laisser emballer
donc c'est pas évident de faire des
vélocipèdes douanes la journaliste
sportif passionné de cyclisme gérard
holtz a participé à cette course un
véritable cadeau d'anniversaire lui qui
fêtait ses 71 ans ce vendredi 8 décembre
c'est un peu comme un moto et en fait
c'est comme la meuh presque de l'enduro
du motocross ou être super souple sur
les bras j'ai il a fallu un petit outil
qui leur est donc je comprends waratahs
super ton engagement est tenu on se
propulse donc en appuyant sur les
pédales à l'avant ici est le problème
regardez le problème
pour la précision de la conduite la
difficulté que c'est ça faut pas mettre
la roue dans les trous on tourner le
guidon comme ça pour tirer sur l'accord
et le patin ici fresnes et bloquent la
roux spécialiste de l'histoire du
vélocipède le japonais kenzo kobayashi
s'est passionné de cyclisme il a fait le
tour du japon en bicyclette a 19 ans
quand comme c'est la première course de
vélo spyder monde donc j'ai senti
vraiment profère l'histoire mais au
physique avec les conditions climatiques
compliquées les cyclistes ont mis près
de quatre heures trente pour boucler les
17 km entre paris et versailles soit
trois heures de plus que les trois
premiers en 1867 selon les récits
historiques
m